[Music]
it's a pleasure and honor to meet you
I'm super excited to talk to you our
mutual friend Jesse hit me up
recently he's like you gotta meet this
guy chat man he's his story's crazy
you're gonna love him
and he was kind of describing few as
he's like how do you like 32 33 31 he's
like he's only like he's only like 31
but he's like my go-to guy for advice
he's like he's my Tuesdays with Maurey
guy he's like this incredible ultra
athlete and badass Navy SEAL but he's
also sort of this obi-wan Kenobi Kenobi
type character who's deeply wise and
that's like right in my wheelhouse man
so well thank you excited to talk to you
yeah that's a blessing to be here
brother thank you
so let's why don't we start with the
whole like Navy SEAL thing man you know
it's it's interesting because you don't
you don't necessarily cut the figure of
what somebody would expect never had a
beard and the beard might be a little
bit long I mean the beard goes with it I
guess
and more I guess we're seeing more and
more military dudes embracing the ultra
the ultra running lifestyle but I mean
you did the whole deal man buds and the
whole thing and the story leading up to
it is is pretty crazy
getting what what what in what what you
had to endure and and undergo to kind of
achieve your dream so talk about that a
little bit yeah and I guess I never
really fit the mold rich because I was
born and raised in North Georgia I never
played sports I had never swam in a
swimming pool right never ran on purpose
never never was in a pool until you were
in the military until I went to yet take
the the PST to get a seal contract yeah
but your mom is a triathlete right yeah
she was bring it down to the pool ever
know she would bring me out on the trail
when I was young you know and allow me
to hike around and kind of follow her
but water was I mean growing up in North
Georgia man like you know we didn't we
lived out in the country so we didn't
have a swimming pool
in like the most swimming you would do
would be like to swim out across the
pond to unhook your fishing lure that
was hung on a log yeah you know what I
mean so like dog paddle was was was my
limit so yeah you know but but I worked
through that I you know when I went to
take that physical standards testing it
was a run swim push up pull up sit up I
failed that thing probably a dozen times
dude but I kept coming back every week I
would take it and improve a little bit a
little bit finally passed with minimum
standards and but where does that where
does the dream to become a seal come
from well and I think for everyone is
different for me personally I was I had
just graduated high school and of course
you know the small town that I'm from
that I was living in there's not a whole
lot of especially back then there wasn't
a whole lot of economic opportunities
there and I didn't like school it just
wasn't for me
mm-hmm so I went to work in the
construction industry and I was I did
that for a few months and I just had
this moment one day while I'm sitting
you know in this you know just
environment that I wasn't enjoying and I
realized that if if I wanted more out of
life if I wanted you know financially
you know spiritually and and visit you
know everything as a whole package I was
going to have to step out of that
environment yeah and I realize that if I
didn't make that move that this that I
was surrounded with was just that was
going to be my lot in life and know like
mentors or anybody like no no no really
prior military you know service in my
family it wasn't about me being a
patriot at the time nothing like that it
was just me wanting more out of life
right you know I always tell I'm always
hesitant when I tell that story
because I don't ever want to sound like
I deserve more or that I'm better than
anyone else because there were a lot of
guys that I worked alongside in that
industry and they were happy with that
life and that's awesome but I wasn't
happy with it yeah you know at the time
just had a little bit more ambition yeah
maybe a little more ambition but you
know I tell people all the time some of
the greatest men that I that I've ever
met in my life have wore overalls every
day of their lives and worked the fields
and they've raised a beautiful family
and and they have this really happy
wholesome complete lifestyle but for me
I just wanted to kind of step out so
that's where the the decision I guess
was born but you could have done a lot
of different things in the military like
what was it about SEAL training man I
just saw I just saw at least that you
weren't it's not like you were a
football player good I just saw this
thing online
I was sitting like I said I was looking
on my computer and researching jobs
within the military and this thing just
pops up I'm talking about Navy SEALs and
I didn't really even know what Navy
SEALs did but it said this is the
hardest military training in the free
world and it was like for something
clicked in my head like boom this is
this is what I'm going to go do mm-hmm
and I can't I can't really explain why
it was that one single thing right but
but yeah from that point forward that
became my mission that became my entire
dream in life is to get on the start
line and at least get a shot you know to
reach this goal that I set for myself so
you sign up for the military you head
off but it doesn't exactly go to plan no
it didn't quite go as as I planned and
so basically what happened rich is you
have to go through navy boot camp before
you go to SEAL training while you're in
boot camp
they run you
a series of medical evaluations to make
sure that your body is physically
perfect they're not going to send you
off to the super arduous training unless
they know you're good to go so I make it
all the way through boot camp and the
last day we have our big final training
exercise and like that is wrapping up
and everybody's heading off to
graduation and my drill instructor comes
to me and says Chad you need to go see
medical they found something that they
need to talk to you about so in that
last moment as as everybody's going off
to you know to chase their dream and
their goals I'm walking over to medical
as I'm just a young kid and thinking
what in the world is this all about and
I walk in to this office and the dive
Medical Officer standing there and he
says Chad we found a pericardial cyst on
your heart and he said this is totally
asymptomatic he said it was never gonna
bother you your whole life but we're
afraid when you go down to depth when
you're diving as a seal that the
pressure change could potentially burst
that cyst on your heart and he said we
can't let you be a seal yeah so he based
all my dreams and aspirations were taken
from me
in that one definitive moment you know I
was I was given this this you know you
can't do this right so how did I feel it
was crud it crushed me man it it crushed
me but the strange thing is is that when
he when he told me that even though this
was the guy in charge telling me that I
couldn't do the things that I wanted to
do for I never let go of that dream yeah
so I I immediately said to myself I'm
going to find some way
over under around this condition you
know even though there's basically I
mean short of heart surgery there's no
way around this right so what are they
what do they do they just reassign you
at that point so they tried that's what
they tried the Navy tried to just send
me out to the fleet which is the big
Navy which is awesome
that's an awesome place to be but it's
not where I had set my roles so how do
you finagle out of that so I reached
back to my family
they made some phone calls and I was
able to get an administrative discharge
from the Navy it was basically because
they had essentially breached the
contract that I had with them because my
contract was to go to seal Tracey so I
got out of the Navy like I say I still
had had aspirations to be a seal and and
the only Avenue
like you said rich was I got to have
heart surgery right so I started going
all these heart surgeons air in Atlanta
and trying and every surgeon I went to
would told me the same thing that the
dive Medical Officer told me this is a
rare condition it's asymptomatic we're
not willing to accept the risk of
performing this surgery even if you
waived all of it even if I waived all of
it they didn't want to just live your
whole life with this thing it's nope
it's no problemo they didn't want to
touch it man uh-huh so I finally find a
surgeon in Atlanta named dr. Cooper and
he had served in the Army as a combat
surgeon downrange and he understood what
I wanted to go do I think more so than
somebody that hasn't served at capacity
how many how many doctors did you go to
before him I was turned down by three
doctors and to the best of my memory it
was three doctors before I finally found
dr. Cooper huh and he's like I'll do it
he was like I'll do it he was a runner
dude awesome I mean I remember my first
appointment like every appointment I had
with this dude would be early in the
morning
and he would be he would come into the
office in his running clothes uh-huh
like still sweating and I'm like this is
this is my guy right here my dude for
you right brother how risky was this
procedure you know and I get asked that
a lot
rich but back then I was I was a kid
dude I wasn't asking these questions I
had a singular focus right I never asked
the question how risky is this I just I
knew that it had to be done for me to
move forward with my with my dream
uh-huh
I think the riskiest part of the surgery
is that the condition was so rare so dr.
Cooper for instance is a well-known
surgeon in Atlanta he had never removed
a pericardial cyst so it was a he pretty
much I remember him pretty much telling
me okay we've got a general plan but
we've never done this surgery before so
we're gonna have to open you up and
we're gonna figure it out you know when
we get in there right so that's right
crack your sternum open that way like an
open heart
they actually detached my PEC muscle
moved it up and then went in through my
ribcage to get to my heart yeah Wow
was her moment beforehand where you
thought like this is insane
there was one distinct moment and it was
it was actually the morning of the
surgery man I was riding to the hospital
with my dad at like 5:00 a.m. and I look
over at my dad I had this moment of
doubt and I look over at my dad and I
said dad do you think I should really go
through with this and he looked back at
me and without stuttering he says son if
you want to be a seal you have no choice
yeah and that resonated with me that's
the way my mind ticks we'll talk about
that I simplify things that resonated
with me and I just said Roger that that
was the truth I had no other choice
right so fueled perhaps by maybe a
little bit of naivete that comes with
youth in that sense of being impervious
and immortal when you're young totally
problem
so you get through it and then what you
go back and just show up and say I'm I'm
ready to go now well it wasn't that easy
I get through it this this surgery was
successful but it was still a gamble
because I still had to get waiver as I
still had to get signed off I you know
the the Navy had to review the civilian
medical documents you know from the
surgery and basically sign off on it so
this whole time I'm just gambling man
how long did that take I can tell you I
was back in the Navy standing before the
same dive medical officer that has that
had disqualified me less than a year
after surgery so I walked back in his
office rich and he looks at me and he
says what are you doing back here man
uh-huh he remembered me because it was
it was rare so so rare and and all this
is written this is a public information
if you just google Navy Seal pericardial
cyst you can read how rare it was in a
medical journal that that doctor wrote
uh-huh and so I hand him over the
documents and he looks him over and I
think that he really respected what I
had done the risk that I had taken right
like this is the kind of crazy we need
here that I understood the doctor
understood it more than anyone else
could have understood because he knew
what was involved with with the surgery
right you know well in the history of
seals had anybody else you must be the
first person that was the first one no
the first case of a pericardial cyst in
a sealed candidate that's ever existed
until now people hear this right alright
so you're back in and then what you just
go from there into buds like how does it
work yeah so luckily the Navy blessed me
off gave me the waiver I needed and they
did not make me go through boot camp
again I had got far enough along that
make me go back through that process so
I am in a holding pattern for a few
months waiting for the buds class to
kind of class up but yeah pretty much
essentially I'm right back in and I
finally get to toe the line there at my
biggest dream and aspiration that I've
ever had and brother nothing was going
to stop me and there's like well like
300 people in a buds class back in those
days yeah I mean it was we were you know
that was a big influx that was 2007 uh
war was going pretty hard right so we've
all those kids in high school that that
were there for 2004 9/11 we're kind of
aging up into that time know so we
started with about 300 guys yeah well my
only frame of reference for wrapping my
head around what goes on at Budds is is
David Goggins and the stories that he's
told on this podcast and what he wrote
in his book I mean what was your
experience like you know buds is a weird
thing rich it's a crazy thing about it
is nothing about buds no singular
evolution is really all that hard man
what do you mean by though like the time
like the timed evolutions that perform
the things that you have to do and Buzz
is like a four-mile time to run uh-huh
you get like 32 minutes to do that you
got to swim two miles
you get ample time to do that so nothing
in buds is really all that hard meaning
like in isolation is visual tasks it's
just the accumulation of them the
hardest thing is when you when you look
at the total pictures the grind man and
that's why that's why dudes quit
essentially I would say that's the
number one reason that people quit it's
just like running alter you know how to
break an ultra down well buds is like
that but magnify it into like a it's
like a six month long ultra yeah right
right so this is kind of part of your
core philosophy right like breaking
things down into the they're sort of
smallest components
so that you can digest them one by one I
think it's essential rich for me in my
life it's yeah it's breaking not only
breaking say a race breaking it down
from you know a tree to tree or rock to
rock perspective but even breaking down
the the outcomes you know when I when I
go and race
I never feel any pressure and I never
really get nervous man because in my
mind I've broken that I've broken that
race down into two outcomes I'm either
going to break my body oh I'm going to
achieve victory or across the finish
line that simplifies it so much for me
and is it is that philosophy advisable
well I don't know I think that's a
choice for every individual to make but
for me I look at these races as as
missions almost like missions in my life
and I'm willing to accept the fact that
I could potentially break myself to
accomplish this mission right well the
other option is to quit quit yeah but
you just don't put that on the table I
won't put it on the table man and and
I'm not by no means am I trying to sound
super tough or I subscribe to this
saying it's be hard when it gets hard
uh-huh and an ultra it gets hard so
that's when I like to hunker down yeah
there's this ethos out there I saw you
kind of speaking about this on Instagram
out there like stay hard you got to be
hard 24/7 you know and I think people in
general need a kick in the pants and
that's a worthy message that I think is
helpful to a lot of people who have
gotten a little too cushy or comfortable
in their lives but staying hard all the
time is not a sustainable lifestyle
philosophy is it it's not sustainable
rich and I really feel like for me
personally it's a dangerous philosophy
because if you have if you think
as a man or a woman that you have to be
hard all the time we said it's not
sustainable so you're gonna fall short
of that mark and when you fall short of
that mark you're gonna beat yourself up
about it
and it just causes problems I feel like
for me personally and it causes problems
in in relationships man you know when
you know when I was active duty you know
I could be out on the road or be on
deployment well when when you come back
you got to be able to to love your
family and and love the other people
around you and show compassion and and
emotion and those are all those aren't
components of being hard all the time
out there Konitz that are necessary to
living a healthy lifestyle oh what's the
point otherwise right but they're not
they're not teaching that to you and
buds no that's something that I had to
learn yeah I mean they turn you into
this I don't want to say monster but
they turn you into what I guess society
we call an alpha male and buds oh yeah
right
so stay hard when it's it's appropriate
to be hard when you need to be hard have
a place inside a yeah that you can that
you can go to when it gets hard and you
can get the job done but couldn't you
make an argument that setting yourself
up with these two options either victory
or you know completely you know going
until your body breaks down that that
could be considered an unsustainable
model - all right that could be yeah
that could be but I mean I'm you know
pick your moments or pick your battles I
suppose and and that's why I say is it
is that specific philosophy advisable I
think it's it's called it's called you
know risk calculation you calculate what
you're willing to accept to accomplish
this mission for me I'm willing to
accept that right you know but
everybody's not me I like this idea of
breaking things down into tiny little
nuggets to achieve your goals I think
people you know this is gonna go up in
the New Year people are thinking about
their new year's resolutions everybody
set this
like aspiration for themselves and as
you know most people you know fall off
the wagon and don't end up self
actualizing whatever it is that they're
looking to do in their lives and I think
I think you know that message is really
important because we get caught up in
the sexy idea of what it's gonna be like
and feel like and look like when we
achieve that goal but we're just not
willing to do those little things every
day that keep us moving in that
trajectory in kind of a relentless way
because it's not sexy because those
little things are tiny little things
they're not things that are gonna get
anybody excited they're just stuff you
got to do relentlessly to create that
kind of momentum that that creates like
a self-perpetuating machined Title II
brother yeah I agree on it right all
right so you're well all right so you're
in buds is it what you thought it would
be expected it to be yeah harder easier
I would say seal training is probably
like the one thing in life that
surpassed its reputation in terms of
difficult in terms of difficulty yeah
and there again that's I'm talking about
the whole the whole picture right now
you know what is the main thing that you
take away from that experience you know
there's so many things that that we
could talk about that were born in that
experience I'd say the one thing that
I'd utilized the most right now is the
lessons that we learned that revolve
around the I call it the power of the
spoken word the the things that we say
how the things that we say impact our
direction in life and the outcome of our
situations and one of the earliest times
I remember seeing seeing this work was
in first phase my best friend came to me
one day and he said Chad I don't think
I'm good enough to make it through this
training anymore
and you know I had known prior to that
statement that he had been having some
thoughts of doubt but when he kept those
thoughts within his own head he was able
to continue from day to day but as soon
as he came to me that that morning and
spoke it out loud that statement he
created that reality it became real it
crushed him man he was crushed by that
single statement I don't think I'm good
enough and it's and shortly after he
made that statement he went in and quit
and I thought you know this guy my buddy
you know he was completely physically
capable of doing everything that we had
to do that day and every single day
until graduation but those words crushed
him man it was like the rubicon once he
once he crossed that
yeah there's no return once you once you
give voice to whatever it is whatever
demon is swimming around in your head it
gives it a gives it a power that you
can't take that there's there's
something about when it's something
about the spoken word man and I think
the the written word has has similar and
equal power but you know a lot of my
stuff
lessons revolve around that spoken word
and now that's transferred that lesson
has transferred into ultrarunning and
you know I've seen that power of the
spoken word push people beyond their
conceived and limits so give me an
example of practicing that so I can give
you an example of how we practice it at
a race a few months ago I we were doing
a Last Man Standing race right so this
is one with Jesse know this was one that
I didn't do the one with Jesse I had
done one a few more four uh-huh so I
became acquainted with a young man named
Thomas Thomas had never ran more than a
10k race before so she's about six miles
and me and Thomas kind of partnered up
and I thought I'm gonna I'm gonna mentor
Thomas and it starts to get you know
we'd been we had made it to like 15
hours so is it one of those were you do
a loop and you get a break and you have
to do it in a certain way I mean just
keep going until no there's only one
person live 6 miles every hour on the
hour until was this the race that you
created we we actually hosted a race
that was a similar format but this was
one I was actually competing in okay so
Thomas we get the the Sun starts to set
and I you know I look in his eyes and I
can tell he's hurting bad man he he's
he's he's almost done and I told Thomas
I said Thomas I just want I want you to
do something for me I said I want you to
just say I will never quit and Thomas
looks over at me and he he says I'll
never quit and I'm like no man I want
you to yell it out loud let everyone
around here know that you will never
quit and I think Thomas kind of thought
that it was cocky but it wasn't about
being cocky it was about us creating
this confidence in this reality for
ourselves through the words that we
spoke so Thomas yelled I will never quit
and then throughout the rest of that
night every time I'd see Thomas we'd
yell back and forth to each other I'll
never quit Thomas ran over a hundred
miles Wow that day so from a 10k he ran
over a hundred miles do you know what
his goal was going in 200-mile it was to
run it was a hundred miles but you know
we we had also made a pact with each
other that uh and and I had I had made
this for myself but I brought Thomas on
board that will never that we wouldn't
die in the chair during that race that
we would die out on the race course when
our time came battling for every step so
on Thomas's last lap he reached his goal
and he said
he's sitting in his chair he said
brother Chad he said I got my hundred
miles man
I'm good uh-huh and I said naw Thomas we
said we're not dying in the chair
brother
so Thomas Thomas rose up out of the
chair man out of that that he did speak
those words out loud
he now you got to overcome them yeah but
maybe it reached his goal essentially he
had every right to be there but he had
just had a little he forgot about don't
die in the chair you know
so Thomas rises up in and and comes back
out toes the line again and he's running
with me and based essentially waiting
for my permission to to end right and
yeah we get out about 300 yards from the
start line and I say all right Thomas
you did it rather good you could have
withheld that permission and just see
you know how much further this guy's
keep it cattle so proud man it was
amazing so what do you what do you make
of that like what is that about like how
is how is it like that the spoken word
can carry that kind of power
it's you know and and I don't know I
don't know what for me something in your
thought that's in your head hmm it's
just a thought it's it's not tangible to
anyone else except for you but when you
speak something out loud it actually
becomes something real something that
can be measured so it becomes something
that's part of this reality that we live
in and and and I feel like that's what
gives it the power the power of the
spoken word I feel like that's why it's
so powerful because as a thought it's
it's essentially it's not part of this
reality that we're living in but as soon
as you speak it it becomes real right
that's where I find a power at man so
the the practical application of that or
the practice of it is to be very
measured or judicious and what comes out
of your mouth and to be careful that
that to be mindful of the words that you
speak such that whatever is coming out
of your mouth is is you know a positive
affirmation that underscores the the
goal that you're trying to achieve I
think you have to be constant constantly
conscious of it man and and it's that
something I practice in my own life and
you know I obviously I take it kind of
some people would think to the extreme
you know I don't curse that's not a I'm
a Christian but that's not a Christian
thing it's because none of those words
in and of themselves have a positive
meaning so I try to stay constantly in
control of my rudder I look I look at my
tongue as my do you ever [ __ ] that up oh
yeah I mean everybody's gonna make
mistakes man for sure but you know a big
thing rich is to be especially aware of
your rudder during times of adversity
right you know because that's when
that's when it really matters when
you're in the struggle when you're in
the furnace of adversity that's when you
have to be really conscious of the
things that you're saying yeah
in my opinion back to Budds was there
ever a breaking moment for you or will
you just and and was this kind of
perspective taught to you or you just
this was an intuitive thing that you
stumbled upon as a survival mechanism to
get through this it so it wasn't all I
think it's been it was an intuitive
thing but I think that it's also
developed now through you know as I get
older and I continue to see at work and
I teach these skills to other people and
then I hear their testimonies when they
come back and say oh my gosh you know I
was in this terrible situation or this
terrible moment and I just spoke life
into my situation and it changed the
direction it changed the outcome those
things all strengthened my faith in
these actual tools that we have right in
Budds there was no breaking point for me
though there was never a time
that I thought about that I thought
about quitting never a single moment I
never looked toward the Bell and and
again that's not because I'm any tougher
than anyone else man but it's because I
had been through a furnace of adversity
prior to even toeing the line so I had
quite a bit invested right so you get
through that and then what where and
what was your deployment like like what
was the experience of actually being a
Navy SEAL
so you know I did multiple deployments
over the course of the 12 years that I
was active duty as far as the experience
of being a Navy SEAL man it's not as
sexy as you would think it's I'll tell
you the best part about being a Navy
SEAL is you get to go to work with
heroes every single day you get to go to
work with these men that are just you
know have integrity these men that just
will not quit and you get to be
surrounded by those people every day
that was the best part of actually being
in the SEAL Teams as far as the
day-to-day job it's a job man yeah you
you know you have a mission every day
whether it's training or you know actual
mission and you're a professional you're
an operator and you get the job done and
it's not you know buddy there's doing it
for glory
at least not you know they may be your
oddball every now and then that that
that's the why they do it but you're
real operators are are just there to get
a job done that needs to be done man
yeah we're in an interesting time now
we're kind of prior to maybe a decade or
so ago nobody who was a Navy SEAL or a
Special Forces soldier really talked
about that experience publicly but then
somebody cracked the seal on that I
wrote a book and then there was there's
been kind of this tremendous amount of
interest in what that experience is like
lots of books lots of people who have
become public speakers and these things
turn into movies and television shows I
don't know how much you're allowed to
talk about your actual missions or
deployment but there is kind of a
public lens on this life that didn't
exist probably when you you know when
you began all of this so how do you like
think about that as somebody who is you
know an alumnus of that experience I'll
tell you rich that's a that's a really
interesting question and I think that
the times that we're in the times we're
living in right now the more
complicating life becomes the more
complicating our society becomes the
more we we have where we have these
devices we have social media the more
complicating life becomes the more
people are hungry for the lessons that
we've learned as at not only as seals
but you know in ultrarunning I think
that's why ultra running is is making
this huge jump right now I think we're
living in a time in that that people are
hungry for these lessons and for this
pure mentality and you know I I could be
just as happy rich if I moved to the
mountains in North Georgia and lived in
a cabin and never spoke to anyone other
than my hands again yeah but I feel like
I would be doing a disservice to my
brothers and sisters my you know
everyone within our community everyone
that listens to this if I didn't at
least come and share with you but things
that I've learned in the things that
have worked for me yeah so you consider
that I call the service I say yeah it's
it's almost it's like for me it's like
continued service it's like I've this is
how I continue my mission is by sharing
the things that that I've been given man
right well I think we are you know in a
moment where you know we've never seen
people as lonely and kind of you know
mentally discontent as they are and yet
we're more prosperous than we ever have
been before it's not about like you know
I can't buy the tell
it's about this social contract that
we've created that prioritizes comfort
and luxury and ease above the things
that actually make us happy which is
connection with other humans and
experience and living outside of your
comfort zone and tackling obstacles and
challenges and also you know I think
it's it's sort of not socially
acceptable to kind of tell people the
hard truth you know in polite
conversation and here comes all these
Navy SEALs who are like that's [ __ ]
man if you want this then you're gonna
have to do that like they're just
they're just they're not mincing words
they're just telling you what you
actually really need to hear if you feel
like you're in a rut or you're trying to
you know kind of you know achieve a
better life for yourself that's right
rich and rich there's a lot of days that
go by that I never talk about being a
sea of life okay when I could do when I
come on these podcasts to talk about
seals like Navy SEALs done huh
it there is a aspect of it that makes me
uncomfortable really to be honest with
you because why because we were trained
to be silent professional race and
that's what we we are the whole time
we're active-duty you you you are a
silent professional and and now I think
the important thing for me now is to
remember the fact that I'm not sharing
these things with you because for my own
glory or to put myself on a pedestal I'm
sharing these things with you because I
love you and I want you to have a
everything that you want I want you to
be able to achieve your goals and you
may be able to do that without me but if
I can help you in any way shape or form
that's my mission man I get that I
believe you to does it feel a little bit
like a betrayal then to talk about it
given that you were trained to kind of
zip it I don't I don't feel like it's a
betrayal because here's the thing rich I
we're not we're not sitting here talking
about the missions that we did we
not sitting here talking about the bad
things the war and the things that
happen there we're talking about tools
that that we can apply in our day-to-day
life right if I was sitting here talking
to you about some mission overseas and
and the intricacy and the details of
that that would be a betrayal but we're
not talking about tactics man right I'm
not telling you anything right now that
an enemy could listen to at some day and
have and get an advantage over the guys
that are still in the fight right now do
you understand that yeah I get that yeah
lately so I don't feel you know that's
why I don't feel like I'm betraying
right anyone yeah I get it
so other than die in the chair don't die
in the chair and you know break things
down into what sit you know immediately
in front of you to do like what are the
other and and the spoken-word thing like
what are the other like big lessons that
you want people that understand um I'd
say another essential and message that
people might take the wrong way I use
this now and ultrarunning and we used it
back you know in training it's don't
give a voice to your pain or suffer in
silence
that was a mantra we had in the teams
and that is not that is not at all
related to mental or emotional pain I'm
talking about physical pain that you
feel during times of self-inflicted
adversity and it's helped me
tremendously in ultrarunning you know
when you're deep into a race man and and
everything hurts and you look over at
your buddy and when you look over at
your buddy remember that your buddy
feels the same pain that you're feeling
huh so what use what's what service are
you doing to him or to yourself if you
say gosh man this hurts so bad like he
already knows it hurts man and that was
how we operated you know you're going
through buds you never looked at you
looked over at your buddy and you said
man that guy's
as cold as I am there's no reason for me
to talk about how cold I am right now
right so it kind of we're you know an
example of how well you utilize it and
ultrarunning or seen it work was did a
race last May called cruel jewel it was
106 miler in North Georgia had 33,000
feet of elevation gain and lost so super
difficult course and this was actually
my first hundred mile er it was it was
two years ago actually and so I'm
running this race I'm doing good
up into about mile 70 and I tore my
hamstring right down here work connects
to the back of my knee and man you won't
talk about hurt and brother it hurt
something terrible and it's got swollen
up and red and but I didn't so I still
had 30 miles left I never said a word to
anyone about it never told an aid
station worker never told my crew like
oh my gosh I tore my hamstring it hurts
like crazy so I can't carry on through
this race and I'm still able to make
ground and I hadn't gave a voice to that
pain until I had five miles left I came
to the last aid station and I lost
control of my rudder man and I told the
aid station worker how bad my hamstring
had been hurting for the last four or
five hours and when I gave a voice to
that physical pain that I was feeling
there again it gave power to that that
pain and that injury and it almost took
control of me from a mental standpoint
when I gave it a voice and I had like
five miles left it took me three hours
to cover that last five miles man so it
crushed me well so you finished I finish
you finish there is an argument that
maybe that wasn't the wisest thing to do
right like there's a difference between
physical pain and the pain that emanates
from like damaging yourself in a really
bad way like if you ripped your
hamstring
I don't think anybody would first of all
no one would give a [ __ ] if you stopped
and it might it like if you had finished
that race with that torn hamstring and
then you were out for like a year
because you just screwed yourself up so
badly there again it's operational risk
management it's your decision man yeah I
didn't care what anybody else thought
this is all these this is all these
missions of mine do you got it you know
what I mean I got it so all right so so
how long were you a seal for that 12
year 12 years yeah I actually just got
out this past January right right one of
the things Jesse told me that you did is
you you were you like bodyguards for
Obama can you talk about that or is that
like off the records yeah I work I work
with Obama a few times yeah yeah yeah
it's been cool yeah oh I enjoyed it yeah
he's a good dude
enjoyed spending time with him it was a
cool experience for sure right so just
one of many spoken like a CEO like I
could tell you don't want to talk too
much about this that's okay
so twelve years and then you get kind of
what's the equivalent of like a an
honorable discharge right like you had
some injuries as a result like there's a
there's a brain injury involved and and
I think some PTSD could you talk about
that a little bit yeah it was more it
was multiple you know just just kind of
its it was kind of looking at the whole
picture of me and then especially
looking at the brain injury stuff I was
a breacher which means we we deal with
explosives we're like an explosives
expert within the platoon and I had been
exposed to you know multiple no telling
how many blasts and I noticed that it it
was affecting me in in different ways
both mentally and physically and finally
I had to go and talk to a doctor about
it I you know it was just it became it
was impacting my performance right you
know out in the field and they basically
said yeah this is what's going on
you don't need to be exposed to this
anymore because we risk really
diminishing your quality of life if we
continue to expose you to this and I was
medically retired got it so basically
exposure to ordnance blasts yep over
however long period of time like time
and time again like the repetitive
nature of that being exposed to that
yeah yeah that's that's a that was
essentially the big one and of course
you know you have joint injuries they
look at the whole picture when they
start thinking about yeah the medical
retirement right so so when you're now
faced with having to return to civilian
life like that is that hard yeah yeah
yeah it's tough rich and I think the
toughest thing about it man is when you
it's the same as a professional athlete
or or a musician or when you have your
entire identity wrapped around this one
thing when when you lose that one thing
whether it's a professional athlete a
CEO a musician whatever it can be can be
a crushing blow yeah so you know I was
blessed in a way that I had found
ultrarunning
that helped me diversify my identity it
helped me you found that when you were
CEO about a year before so when they
started talking about the whole medical
retirement thing I started ultrarunning
because that was a really stressful time
for me man I don't like going to the
doctor I was going to the doctor like
three times a day and it was driving me
crazy
so I started ultrarunning right off the
bat or just like I'm gonna run like most
people start running you know I'm gonna
go run around the base or something like
that like they're not like I'm gonna be
an ultra runner was it was it that baked
in from the beginning like I'm gonna do
ultras yeah I never I mean I had never
ran a marathon
um any I've never ran a 10k I just I
signed up for a 50-mile race the first
race he signed up for the first race it
was the Iron Mountain ultra marathon in
Omaha skis Virginia so yeah I signed up
for that racing went out there and it
completely obliterated me but I I saw
the community there like I really loved
the community like that grassroots feel
it was all it's almost like family dude
like when I'm out on the trail
I'm calling guys like brother sister and
and because I legitimately view them as
my brother or sister it's like family I
loved it and I loved how that event
crushed me it like broke down all these
barriers that we have built up you know
between each other hmm man when you're
out there and you just crush yourself
all these barriers just crumble and like
an ultra is the one place that I can
truly like let my emotions just flow and
I can cry if I want to cry I can laugh I
can get angry
it doesn't matter those and that was
something that as an operator you didn't
really show emotion you know kind of
train that way not to show emotion so
you have this opportunity to express
that in a different way yeah it almost
it makes it it brings you back to like a
pure form of humanity yeah it's almost
like that's what you need it in order to
be integrated once again and you found a
way to figure that out through this
vehicle of running that's it yeah so but
it was still it was still when I finally
was separated from the Navy it was still
tough man because I was still in a sense
when I got out of the Navy I was still
trying to like hang on to all those
things that I had done as a seal and I
was trying to
depend upon those things to like move me
forward into the into my future life
right but I had a vision one night man
and I was able to to let go of all that
old stuff because a ship doesn't sail on
yesterday's wind right and and and when
I when I had that vision and I was able
to let go it allowed me to then propel
myself into the life I'm living now
right well if you think we're just gonna
blow by the fact that you have this
vision without me asking you about it
you're the same so tell me about this
vision man I'll tell you about it and I
this is probably the first time I've
talked about this publicly but I'm late
so I'm in that place where like we
talked about I'm depending on I'm
hanging on to all this old stuff
thinking that it's just gonna move me
forward in life from a career standpoint
from a social standpoint you know still
kind of hanging on to that identity and
I'm laying in bed one night and I'm just
frustrated rich and in my mind's eye as
I'm laying in bed I'm awake and I see a
scroll up here in front of me in the
center of my vision and on that scroll
was written everything that I was
hanging on to it was like a resume
essentially and as I'm looking at the
scroll I'm like what in the world like I
like an old tough like an ancient like
an iris scroll or something man yeah it
was like an old scroll and and so I'm
really my resume all this cool stuff
I've done so around that scroll these
clouds dark clouds started to build and
as those clouds were building that
scroll began to shrink
well what those clouds came to me in
that moment those clouds represented the
of my god and as the presence of God
built around this scroll it's shrunk and
it continued to shrink and the presence
of God continue to build and the scroll
got so tiny that I could no longer read
the words written on the scroll so what
do you make I have some ideas but don't
tell me how you interpret it so how how
I interpreted that was my God was
telling me in that moment that Chad I
can do so much more than what you have
done but you've got to let go of these
things that you're hanging on to if you
want to let me work with in your life
and propel you forward into into your
new mission you've got to let go of
these and and when I got in when I had
that revelation when that was revealed
to me the message of that vision I no
longer looked at that scroll as a resume
I looked at it as a tomb mmm they were
actually things that I thought you know
I could that could propel me forward but
they were actually things that in
reality were going to hold me back so I
gave it all I was able in that moment
when I when I when I figured out the
message here I was able to let it all go
go and move forward now into my future
with just this clean and pure ass you
know perspective and just just let go
and I'm also able now to really see the
design within my life the things that
are orchestrated obviously by something
larger than more powerful than more
powerful than me but you know I couldn't
see that before man because I was
depending upon myself forever
right I mean that's a beautiful
spiritual experience you know what I
what I see in that is somebody who was
holding on very tightly to this story
this identity who you who you tell
yourself you are and like kind of
hanging your ego on these pegs based on
these experiences that you've had and
the journey forward to wholeness to this
next chapter was to surrender all of
that to like lay it down at the feet of
God right basically basically to set
aside your ego and just be open to
possibilities and kind of wipe that
chalkboard cleaned so that's a hard
thing to do it is you know I mean these
like when I was in rehab I kind of had I
had my own version of that like learning
how to you know really surrender and I
think for somebody who is a type-a
personality or somebody who like look
clearly you had this dream of becoming a
seal and nothing was gonna get in the
way of that and the only person that was
gonna make it happen was you so you're
you were somebody who is kind of crafted
you know sort of born out of this
willfulness like self will right and I'm
sure you have a million things that you
can point to in your memory and
experiences to say I would have died had
I not done that or I took care of that
and it's all me me me but in order to
broaden your life experience ultimately
you have to realize the limitations of
self well on that really in reality self
will is your biggest limiter but that's
something that's very difficult to let
go of for somebody who is accomplished
or somebody who you know knows how to
set a goal and achieve it yeah yeah and
it was essential for me to to be able to
let I'm not saying you know I had to I
it was essential in that moment because
I had you know that part of my identity
had ended and I had to move forward you
know right but you hit the nail on the
head rich I mean that that is the right
a perfect interpretation of that vision
you so you speak it so much more
eloquent now and I like I like your
version but I want to I want to talk
about I want to talk
your faith more because I think it's
super interesting I mean you first of
all you have this wild story you know
one of the catalysts that brought you
into your spiritual perspective can you
share that you know what I'm talking
about oh yeah yeah I mean you weren't
you you weren't born and bred you know
reading the Bible every day right like
this is a this is a newer thing it is
rich and I'll you know I'll talk to you
about my faith but I want to preface it
with this by no means am I telling
anyone what they should do all I can do
is tell you what has worked for me and
why I can tell you the stories of why I
believe how I believe uh-huh that's all
there is to it brother Rishi ate it so
yeah when I essentially and I'll use
some some Jesus talk now okay when I
when I have my come to Jesus moment was
actually while I was overseas and I had
no you know spiritual spirituality that
was just wasn't a part of my life man
had no connection to to a God didn't
grow up with it you know it was it was I
have to say it was on and off as we were
coming up as children but you know I at
that point I had branched off and I was
living my own life man you know I had me
personally I had no personal
relationship to of God yeah
so we're staying in this place overseas
and one it was only there was four of us
one of the four guys was a Christian and
we're staying in this building and the
one that was a Christian he started
reading his Bible every evening well
sounds crazy brother but when he started
doing that these weird things started
happening within this place we were
staying uh-huh and they were I call them
now it was it was really an evil thing
so the things that were happening
we're causing fear and discontent and
discomfort within our group so he starts
reading his Bible he obviously
aggravates this spiritual presence this
other spiritual presence that is
dwelling in this place right you're
talking about paranormal paranoia so
yeah I remember the first thing like
laying in bed one night and something
hits my door and I hear like singing up
and down the hallways of this place
where we were staying and I get up and
everybody's passed out and it they it
scared me
what kind of singing um it would did it
I don't remember it as sound and it was
not words it was more just like tones
tones flowing up and down the hallway
and it didn't have an evil sound to it
but the event had fear attached to it
right and hearing some kind of not like
a house but like a build you're on a
mission yes yeah yeah we're on we're on
deployment and and so as as the day's
progress these this Paranormal Activity
continues to happen and also our moods
as like as teammates this spiritual
presence was bearing down on our moods
and and it got to the point where it was
affecting our interactions with each
other and you know the way we felt about
each other and just really just getting
us in a rut man so you're not the only
one who's experienced so eventually
after you know after a week or so you
you got you got four Navy SEALs sleeping
in the same room together because
they're they're freaked out about what's
going on right like these super badasses
now all have left their respective rooms
and you're all sleeping in the same
that's it my man so all right hold on a
second so what was that like the first
time like when this happens to you you
must think either I'm imagining
something or or I'm the only one who's
having this experience right
so at some point you you have to
somebody you have to have a conversation
with someone else like hey I heard this
thing did you hear it too like how did
that go yeah oh we were so close I mean
it was like you know we did you hear
that
exactly hey what what hap so what
happened in your room last night and we
you know we would we would talk about
these things and it wasn't necessarily
at night I mean this place you could
walk into this it got to a point where
you could walk into this place and like
I remember there was a stairwell and
like the stairwell went up and then it
cut back so as I was walking up the
first portion of the stairwell I could
feel a presence of something up in
behind me watching me and bearing down
on me as I enter this place and and when
I would make that turn I would fully
expect to see something people standing
there but I never did so we're talking
about it man and it's obvious that that
this crazy stuff is going on and it's
obviously it was obviously initiated by
the the the spiritual side of our one
teammate that that had that as a part of
his life right he opened up this
Pandora's box of little spirits raining
down upon you so real so I dig it I'm
into we're in this like a crazy battle
of good and evil and finally I get sick
of it dude and I called my brother back
home in the States and I knew that my
brother was a Christian he had made that
decision long ago and I knew about that
and I said look like I don't know what's
going on here man
but I'm tired of this I can't rest we
can't work together as teammates it's
this is just getting out of hand
do you do you have any advice what can
we do here because I'm sick of it and he
he said well let me put you in touch
with my pastor he puts me in touch with
the pastor of his local church there
that gentleman calls me up back overseas
and says hey I got an idea of what's
going on here will you put me on
speakerphone and and allow me to walk
walk around this building will you allow
me to pray over this space essentially
he's gonna perform an exorcism right I
actually when this went down I waited
for everyone else to leave because I
thought that even though every this was
so real to all of us like I'm taking it
one like a step too far Brian and you're
like all of two days into Bible study at
this point man yeah so I walk around
this building with this this guy that I
don't know never met before
praying over this area and then he says
hey go get some olive oil and we're
gonna I'm gonna we're gonna anoint the
door and I'm I I come on man get some
all poured in a little cup he continues
to pray and I just take my finger and
anoint the door uh-huh of the place we
were staying in like the outside door
the outside door and also the door to
the room that we were staying right okay
and so after I did this man complete and
total peace returned to this place and
to our mood our relationships within our
team it was like it was like I can
breathe again that's bananas and and so
it blew me away and I was like okay
there is some power here maybe I should
look into this because of this
experience that I just had it was so
real so I went out and bought me a Bible
and and I start digging into the
teachings of this guy named Jesus and
throughout the rest of that deployment
there were things that happened there
really set my faith into concrete give
me an example all that I'll give you one
single example we were out playing one
day and we were in this waterway that
was filled with trash and dead bodies
and I was waterskiing on a spine board
for fun hmm and I fell off and fell into
this water with literally with decaying
human beings around me it's just that
the terribleness of the place that we
were in and I get a gut full of this
water and I get up back up on our vessel
and I shouldn't have been doing what I
was doing in the first place right but
our medic starts freaking out he's like
dude this is bad like this this is not
good and I had remembered I had been
studying the Bible for about a month
prior to this event and I remembered
when the Bible the Bible said if you
know if if you'll speak my words out
loud if you'll if you'll if you'll
remember the scripture and use it it's
it'll work for you that's essentially
you know a simple message of the Bible
and I had remembered a scripture that
said no pestilence or plague shall come
near unto me and I spoke when my you
know when this happened I told my group
I said I'm good bro no pestilence or
plague she'll come near unto me and I
used that scripture in front of a group
of unbelievers and I was totally fine
from that point forward never it never
had any any sickness or issues now that
could potentially be coincidence but you
know that's just one example and so
these things continue to happen
throughout deployment then I get home
and my wife was dying from a disease
called addiction and I had this newfound
faith
and I started to learn about addiction
obviously because I was about to lose
her but that I realized that there was
nothing that I could say to change her
mind so all I did was I was using this
new tool that I had now called prayer
mm-hmm and I prayed I would March
circles around my house pray over the
place in bed where she slept and after
about a month of that she came to me one
day and she said hey I want to get clean
there was no reason for it I wasn't
having this discussion with her about
hey you need to get clean you need to
get in rehab I knew how helpless I was
so I just shut my mouth man and so there
again I take that as my my prayers and
affirmation of it an affirmation of the
prayers that you know that I had said
and you know of course there's going to
be 10,000 people listen to this and just
say that's all coincidence it doesn't
matter this is your experience yeah it's
just it's just my experience man and
that's that's what I'm saying all I can
tell you is the design that I've seen
within my life and then you know so that
event in and of itself
you know was was another thing that you
really just just set my faith in
concrete and made me say well oh my gosh
you know here here is this loving God
that has actually honored my prayers
because I have I have chose to serve Him
yeah you know I'm sorry to hear about
your wife so you come back after
deployment and she's struggling with
this thing I mean that's a very you know
powerless place to find yourself yeah
yeah yeah and but it but it was there
again rich I mean it's one of those
things that first of all I didn't know
anything about addiction and I always
looked down on addicts but walking
through this when I when I was when I
walked as I walked through this with my
wife I realized that addicts are some of
the best
people on earth if they can just get
clean so it changed my whole perspective
on addiction mmm so thankful for that
man when I see somebody struggling with
that drug addiction or alcohol never do
I look down upon them because I know
they're just bound up with these chains
man and if they can break these chains
they're gonna be some of the best people
on earth sometimes most of the time I
was second that yeah you know I think I
think there's a lot of people that
suffer from addiction and alcoholism
that are in a certain respect spiritual
seekers they're just seeking their
answers in an unhealthy way and they
fall prey to this thing that becomes
very difficult to you know claw out of
but when you it and and I believe
strongly that this that that a huge part
of the solution is spiritual like you
have to find a spiritual connection you
have to you have to whether a version of
what you experienced with the scroll
right like you have to surrender
yourself you have to understand that
there's a Power greater than yourself
that you can avail yourself of to help
you confront this thing and it's about
relinquishing the ego and and self well
that's a big part of it mmm-hmm I think
so she's okay now though she's awesome
I'll tell you rich it's there again you
know we we went through that that
furnace of adversity together within you
know as I'm as a as a married couple and
of course her her portion of that was a
lot more painful than my portion all my
pain came just through watching the pain
that she was going through I can only
tell my side of that that journey of
course but um but you know we went
through that together rich and we came
out the other end brother and we got the
best marriage on earth like she's my
best friend in the world and everything
is just wonderful but it's because we
can
I appreciate the time that we have
together now yeah so adversities a tool
man yeah that's all it is well one of
the things that you've talked about that
that I love and I agree with completely
is this idea that the intensity of
adversity tends to ratchet up or
increase the closer you get to
accomplishing the goal right it's almost
like you know the closer that you got to
becoming a seal you got thrown this
thing that seemed like it was an
impossible obstacle that you had to
overcome or the closer you get to the
finish line of an ultra that's when you
know it becomes the hardest and I look
at that and I see it getting played out
time and time again and no matter what
people are trying to accomplish or
achieve and it's I I think of it as like
a spiritual test like okay this is the
thing you want we're gonna work towards
that but before before I let you have it
let's just make sure that you're
actually ready for it you know well not
only is it a test but it's the laws of
nature okay did you know library did you
know rich that we can look at these
things around us this knit this nature
that we live in and that you can take
principles from nature and see the
application in life so what you just
said did you know that this is a fact
that the darkest and coldest part of
every single night is right before the
dawn breaks mm-hmm that is the darkest
and coldest part of a night and you know
that from ultrarunning man yeah man when
you get to those hours that are like
three four five right there before the
dawn is about to break oh my gosh it is
if it's wintertime race you know that's
the coldest part of the night man
right and so that's a law of nature and
it's it that all that stuff transfers
into into life in my opinion I look look
at the lessons and within nature and see
the parallels and
right so what is the relationship
between your faith and ultrarunning like
what does that interplay look like for
you I think a big part of talk about
faith faith in and of itself riches all
that word means to me is that I believe
in something bigger than myself that I
can't see or put my hands on I think the
the the better question that I might
could answer is how does altar running
help me from a spiritual physical and
emotional aspect those so from a body
soul spirit aspect so I don't feel like
ultrarunning in any way impacts my faith
it doesn't it doesn't make me believe
any more or less in a God
but it does help me from a body soul
spirit standpoint which then in turn
brings me closer to God but doesn't
necessarily and it allows me to listen
to him and be in tune with him more so
than I could without also running you
know right so ultra running rich
essentially when you're when you're
ultra running it is a body and soul
exercise and it for a lot of people it's
just also a spiritual thing but when
you're ultra running you are mastering
you're bringing your flesh into
subjection you're making your flesh your
body do what you want it to do so you're
training the body you're making it
stronger you're you're building that
discipline and from a soul perspective
the soul being the mind will and
emotions that's what that's what our
soul is it's it's what do we want to do
or not want to do how do we feel about a
certain activity your disciplining your
mind will and emotions and your bringing
those the aspects of your soul also into
subjection and then from a spiritual
standpoint for me just being in nature
what I would call God
creation is how it nurtures me from a
spiritual standpoint all these trees and
plants and stuff me and all the stuffs
alive yeah man it's all alive man yeah
so I love that that was beautifully put
I would imagine that you didn't expect
to have that kind of broad perspective
when you signed up for that first
50-miler right like how did you come
into this love affair with this sport
well there again for me rich it was that
first one it was I was that doubt that
you up it was it was that it just it
just broke me down it broke these walls
down it you know it was it was that body
soul spirit type thing and I was able to
identify how how ultrarunning was
helping me master nourish and maintain
those three aspects of alright he has a
human you know and after and also the
community I loved the community that was
another break one man well I would
imagine a big part of of having to kind
of weather the transition into civilian
life is is that you is that you don't
have these guides that your that you
have such an intimate relationship with
like these teammates like the
Brotherhood and all of that is sort of
gone and you have to figure out another
way to build that into your life right
so that community I'm sure played a part
in that and there is something very
specific about ultrarunning that when
you're trying to answer these big
questions for yourself like okay well
what am I going to do now with my life
all that solitude and that connection
with nature is a great way to kind of
wrestle with those questions to try to
find the answers for yourself
it is it is yeah yeah and and there you
talk about that solitude and that
connection with nature you know I get I
get so much energy from the living
things within nature like it's happened
to me only twice but I I can distinctly
remember two times I was leaning against
three for a long period of time and I
actually was able to feel the life and
almost personality of this tree like
pass through me or into me I could feel
it right right in here where my where my
heart is and like you're having a
psychedelic experience right yeah but
I've never done drugs before man but it
was I think your brain is dripping DMT
and your system like that you have all
these visions I realize that this dang
this stuff this stuff is alive man like
we can get energy we can get perspective
we can get that from from nature and the
things that are living in nature uh-huh
so that's a big like we see it like
there's something about ultrarunning
that strips away you know everything you
know that gets in the way of being able
to have that connection yeah totally man
yeah so I think that's a big part of
those walls you know tearing those walls
down but there's a difference between
hey you know I like this ultrarunning
thing and like winning races and just
like doing these super crazy rate like
you've you've created quite a career for
yourself as an ultra runner like you've
been super successful I want to talk
about this revenant race we talked about
that yeah yeah yeah last year when did
you do that was last year and then we'll
be going we're going or I'm going down
about this year obviously to give it
another go
but the revenant is a very unique event
held on the South Island of New Zealand
and the basic format of the race it's
450 kilometre loops but it's all off
trail and you have to navigate the
course with map and compass uh-huh
so it's very similar I'm sure you've
heard of the Berkeley man yeah of course
it's Bart Berkeley gets all the press
but this revenant one's even harder yeah
it's well I mean each every race is it's
hard to say which race is harder than
the other because they all have their
specific you know difficulties but yeah
the the terrain on the South Island New
Zealand is very
very hard to get through it's very harsh
environment and then also too you have
weather I would say you know the weather
in in New Zealand is is just as extreme
if not more extreme as the weather you
would experience in Tennessee you know
so it uh yeah it's we went out and I
gave it the first shot last year and
made it around one loop so hold on a
second first of all so this race it also
has like a hundred and five thousand
feet of vertical game - yeah yeah it's
got a lot of climbing bushwhacking and
prior to your involvement with this race
not a single person had ever completed
one loop let alone four yeah yeah how
many years is the race been around um
well actually the the so the the thing
is last year was the inaugural winner of
the race yeah so this was this was
something that the race director has the
race director Scott Worthington he's he
has went out and designed this course
and he has done this course under
perfect condition so he knows it can be
completed but but there's so many things
when you're doing a race like this that
are out of your control my environmental
factors you know what I mean right so
you know that's what makes it different
than a normal hundred mile er is if you
have inversion layer move in and it's so
foggy you can't see the ground you're
standing on
you can't navigate in that type of
environment right where's a normal race
you're just on a trail where your head
down you can turn everything off and
rock and roll so you show up for this
thing there's crazy unprecedented
weather but you're able to do a loop
right you're the only person who's done
a loop um there were I think three
people that did that finished one lower
last year no one finished a second loop
I got that one loop is the most that's
been done on the course yeah I mean we
got through it man it wasn't pretty my
favorite thing are these the
races that no one has ever actually
completed yeah well these Last Man
Standing races you know just a different
way to compete with yourself yeah I love
them too many yeah so how did you how
did you get connected with Jesse Jesse
was training for a Last Man Standing
event uh-huh and he actually hit me up
on Instagram I just had created this
newfangled Instagram account last May
uh-huh so uh yeah he hit me up and said
hey man you can't you can't be on
Instagram when you're a Navy SEAL yeah
so much yeah my buddy was like you got
to do this Instagram thing and I got on
there Jesse heating me up it's it's been
a blessing time that's been an awesome
platform to share the message you got on
now but he just invited me to come out
and run with him and my brother Mark
Brown and we spent a day we ran 50 miles
that day there were a few rules that I
had you know set in place for our group
that day and we hit it off I mean what
were the rules what do you mean you sent
rules so the rules for the day where we
had to run until I said stop we didn't I
didn't want them to know where the
finish line was because we were really
trying to replicate the environment that
they were going to experience that the
last man standing event we had to share
one thing every hour that we were
thankful for with each other that's cool
three grown men yeah might that might
sound silly right no I don't think
that's not I think that's cool yeah it
was it was it was so cool because like
when when Jesse or Mark would share
something that they were thankful for it
might have been something that by no
means applies to my life but just them
expressing that thankfulness like gave
me a boost of energy yeah so that was
the point in that exercise was to really
keep our speech revolving around things
that we were thankful for and things
that positivity right last rule no
cussing same stuff spoken
man so right yeah we ran if we ran fifty
miles together you know the bonds that
form in in those times and that was that
and that was it I mean how can you not
like how could you not like being around
Jesse and you don't know mark yeah yeah
well for those that are listening we got
the two guys here sitting like right off
camera I mean and Jesse is such an
amazing person yeah he said he's a he's
such a beautiful and also charismatic
natural leader and he's just all about
the group you know what I mean
you spent 15 minutes around Jesse you're
gonna feel like you can conquer the
world I know I know he's very gifted I'm
so thankful for his friendship and you
know he's taught me so much you know you
talked about Jesse saying I was his like
go-to guy well Jesse's also my go-to guy
you know we it's it's a friendship we
just share with each other the lessons
that that have worked for us right so do
you live around Atlanta now or where do
where do you call home we just moved
back to Atlanta my wife and I about
three or three or four weeks ago
okay yeah so we just left Virginia Beach
and we're loving life man I know what
George is awesome
what's uh what's a typical day look like
for you training wise um so typical day
rich I wake up in the morning around 6
o'clock I give the first fruits of my
day to God so that maybe that's five
minutes maybe that's 45 minutes either
studying his word or prayer move on from
there a French press a little coffee get
a cup of coffee in and then I'm training
from 8:00 you know 7:00 or 8:00 in the
morning until noon mm-hmm so I'm taking
a four I'm blocking out four to five
hours a day usually to train that is all
dependent on what I'm training for or
where I'm at within that training cycle
so it could be a four hour hike it could
be a thirty mile run
it could be intervals it could be
interval it could be a long run plus
strength training it's different
depending on obviously what I'm
training do you work with a coach or are
you doing this yourself yeah I don't I
don't work with a coach and you know
I've been we've been doing I've been
doing kind of hard stuff running
endurance type stuff for so long I mean
that all that stuff was born in the in
the SEAL Teams you know that um I just
I've reached a point that I can listen
to my body and kind of know when I need
to push hard and when I need to back off
so I haven't really got to the point
that I need a coach yet right and what
are you currently training for like
what's what's the big race that you're
keying on right now so the revenant in
January that's that's a big one and then
I'll probably do cruel Jule again in May
that race in North Georgia where tore my
hamstring I actually finished eighth
place out there two years ago so I'm
thinking I can go back now with a little
more knowledge and a stronger body and
hopefully you know do very much better
and what about Berkeley um let me I got
a crack the revenue yes man I mean yeah
well talking about Berkeley
well let's pivot a little bit to talking
about like I'm interested in hearing
more about you know your wisdom that
could be helpful to people that are
listening out there we're embarking on a
new year and you know like I said at the
outset you know people are trying to
wrap their heads around how to achieve
these goals that they've set for
themselves and what do you think are
some of the biggest obstacles that
people put in front of themselves
unnecessarily so one of the one of the
big ones for me personally is
overthinking stuff man
and that just I mean it just goes back
to to simplifying a situation you know
so if you set a goal for yourself or you
might be trying to establish a goal for
me there's only two questions is this
something that you want
and are you going to have fun along the
journey along the way so whatever that
goal may be instead of sitting there
thinking about it and stressing about
and thinking about everything that's
that could potentially stop you or
hinder you just make sure it's what you
want make sure you're gonna have fun on
the journey to accomplishing that goal
and then just rock and roll with it get
started you start surrounding yourself
with with the people that are that are
going to help you the people that might
have the knowledge that you need to
accomplish that goal start you know
utilizing your time better to you know
to accomplish your goal or to reach the
point that you're trying to it's
utilizing all those tools that the
universal tools that we all have we have
people we have time all of us have these
things some of us may have a little more
than others but that doesn't matter what
about the guy who sends you with DM on
Instagram and says man I'm so inspired
by all these things that you've done I'd
love to run an ultra one day but like
you know I I life Stu busy for that
oh man you have time for what you what
you make time for man your life that to
me it's not a valid excuse dude here's
the thing at that specific question I
just did to know a month ago I did two
back-to-back hundred mile races I did a
hundred mile er called the Georgia jewel
I placed second place there the week
after that I did another hundred mile ER
with Jesse so back-to-back prior to
those races the three months prior to
those races I had only averaged about 20
miles per week of training Wow so the
the time commitment if people people
just blow up the training cycle that
that they think has to proceed these
races man you know the time commitment
is not that that significant and
was the idea that before you're gonna
run 100 miler you got to put in two
years of consistent hundred mile weeks
exactly man I just I don't I don't
subscribe to that there again I think
somebody that that doesn't have much
running background if they if they
surround themselves with people that can
kind of give them the right the right
advice from a mindset standpoint and
also just from how to take care of
yourself standpoint that that the
training commitment is not that great
it's it's all for me it's all about just
having a strong healthy body and
spending time on your feet man yeah so
what is the the mental routine that you
that you utilize to get your head right
for these things I mean I guess it's
baked into you at this point but if you
were coaching somebody who you know
isn't skilled at at you know measuring
their spoken words or you know doesn't
quite have the ability to kind of master
their emotional state because they're
you know have some mental weaknesses
like how do you get that person to the
next level I would tell them after we
talked about the spoken word we talked
about all those tools when the pain gets
when this self-inflicted pain when it
gets to be significant and you think
that you just cannot handle it the
biggest thing that I do is I stop
fighting against it and I understand
that like I I reached this steady state
I call it the steady state to where yeah
it hurts but I understand that it's not
going to hurt any worse because it
already hurts as bad and you know as bad
as it can and then I stopped fighting
against the pain because when you fight
like when you're using your your energy
like emotionally to like battle against
this pain and
you're hating it you know you're just
hating this feeling that you're having
it actually gives that pain more power
over you and I learned this in trend and
buds man with the cold when they put us
in a surf zone and yeah and frees us to
death it's like when you would fight
against the cold
you just got colder and you were just
more miserable but when you just
accepted the fact that oh I'm cold and
you just let that feeling just pass
through you it's it's like freeing you
free up this well of energy that you can
then use to to carry on with your
mission right right and how does that
play out in other areas of your life
outside of running outside of running so
I'll tell you rich how that plays out is
we talk about not fighting against the
things that that we hate like I hate the
cold so I stop fighting against the cold
in my life or in in all of our lives we
only have a certain amount of energy
every single day so we choose how we
want to use our energy every every
interaction that we have every post we
make every email we respond to every
word we say is a withdrawal from our
tank of energy I try to remain
constantly aware of how I'm using that
precious energy and I use that energy
never to fight against the things that I
might not agree with the things that I
might hate but I try to use that energy
to foster and promote the things that
have worked for me that I believed and
have found to be true and pure and and
the message that that I've been
delivered you know so using that energy
not fighting against the things that you
might hate because that's just going to
grind
you down man no matter what the issue is
if it's a political or a social issue
you're wasting your time and usually
it's not effective anyway it's not
usually you can make the biggest impact
on the things that you hate hmm by
promoting the things that you love and
it's so much easier to promote the
things that you love I think that's very
wise and we could all use a little bit
more of that particularly in our public
discourse and on social media and
there's a you know there is a
significant portion of the population
that exerts a huge amount of energy
trying to tear other people down or just
getting into arguments and fighting with
people and it's not effective and I
think it wears on your soul and I think
there's a sense of like weirdly look
there's a sense of accomplishment that
people have when they do it like they
think that they've actually like if you
feel strongly about something and you
criticize somebody else because they see
the world differently there's a sense
that you actually are advancing your
cause by doing that and I think that
that's an illusion and I think it's it's
it it really does kind of I wrote it
there's an erosion on yourself when you
participate in that and I I'm always
challenged though because I think it is
important to speak up for what you
believe in right and there's a lot of
dissonance out there right now and
there's a lot of problems in the world
and a lot of you know things that we
could be doing better that we're not
doing but what is the best way to
accomplish those things yeah you know
totally and this it's like I said rich
this is this is just my perspective
management just works for what works for
me I think you're you know you saying
that yeah you should stand up for the
things that you believe in like yes that
has validity but you know to put this in
practical terms if there's an issue in
today's society that I don't agree with
you're not going to find me in town
holding a poster board right marching
against this cause you're not going to
find me posting things out into so
so media that are warring against this
cause you're gonna find me marching for
the things that I believe in and to be
pure and true it's so much easier to do
that yeah I know that's a way better
life better for you too okay in brother
you know no kid so what is the bigot
we're gonna wrap this up in a minute but
what what is the what is the thing that
you're still struggling with like when
you look at yourself or you know where
you want to do better and be better like
talk to me about the obstacles that
you're grappling with now and how you're
trying to overcome them I would say one
of the biggest obstacles that I'm I'm
grappling with right now and I hate even
calling it an obstacle man because it's
just something that I need to an
opportunity yeah it's just something
that I'm aware of right now is that kind
of as as things as my life starts
rolling now and and you know as things
kind of grow and get bigger with three
of seven and and the stuff that we have
going on the biggest thing that I try to
remain aware of is I never want all this
all the stuff like all the social media
and and just all the the phone calls and
the emails I never want that to get in
the way of our tarnish the purity of
myself or the things that I that that I
my message yeah you know what I mean so
that's something that I that's right so
I just try to stay aware of that man and
and not that I'm not that I'm famous or
anything on any in any I'm not even
close to that but things you know are
the influence with three of seven we get
you know I get messages every day and
you know it takes time to respond all
that stuff and I have to say okay this
four or five-hour block in the morning
this is non-negotiable this is my time
to go spend in the woods doing what I
love to do because if I don't keep my
own ship in order I can't do anything
for anybody else yeah so maybe that sums
it up keeping my own ship in order so I
can carry on be the best advocate that
you can be and I feel you man and it
gets you know it gets it gets hard to do
rather well basically people dangle in
front of you like you know shiny things
like cool opportunities to go to cool
places and do cool stuff
yeah and and sometimes that's great you
know but also it can be at the cost of
making sure that you have boundaries
around those things so I've been on both
sides of that and it gets it's it's hard
but I think your your your heads in the
right place with trying to make sure
that you protect that because without
that there's nothing there's nothing man
you know there's nothing and also being
the best husband that I can be that's
another thing you know that's part of my
shift as I say keeping my own ship in
order that that's my wife and I our
family a view that as a whole right you
know so that's all part of that man cool
all right well let's end this with a
final thought for the person who's who's
out there and feels stuck there in a rut
maybe they're not happy with their job
or they're trying to get off the couch
and move their body for the first time
in a long time like how do we how do we
cattle-prod
that that that that dude or that young
lady to get after it a little bit more
come on man bring us home man I am not
much of a liar use my life coach bro I
am not much of a cattle prodder that's a
that's the thing rich I mean like I said
I just I'm so hesitant to give advice or
to try to tell someone what to do I mean
I I guess I could just keep it super
simple and and and you know go over the
things we talked about simplify things
don't be afraid to put yourself in
adverse situations because that's where
you're going to grow as a human being
the decisions you make in times of
adversity self-inflicted or or totally
out of your control are the things that
those decisions define who you are as a
human but don't fear inflicting that
adversity on yourself because it's going
to help you grow as a human being so I
would say go put yourself through a
little adversity it may be it may be
only running for five minutes to start
with it may not be running I may be
something completely different than that
yeah but don't fear it because I feel
like it's essential for us as humans to
experience that in life and the last
thing that I would say is if you're
struggling emotionally from that kind of
aspect is take a look at your body soul
and spirit look at those three aspects
of your humanity each as a single length
and think about what are you doing on a
day-to-day basis to master nourish and
maintain your body your soul and spirit
and usually that can be used as a
diagnostic to see okay I am lacking here
I'm lacking and I need to get some help
with my emotional side my will what I
want and don't want to do do I want to
get out of bed in the morning do I not
want to get out of it you know that type
of stuff and then the spiritual side you
know that can be it doesn't matter what
it is it could be spending time in
nature for me it's spending time in
God's Word it could it could be anything
you know right well for somebody who is
very reluctant to provide a little I
mean I guess I called it the cattle prod
but you know a little wisdom and advice
I think that's very beautifully said man
thank you rich I appreciate it thank you
for coming here today I appreciate it
and thank you for your service and
please come back and talk to me some
more about Roger take it next time we
got it we got to go running now oh yeah
you went running in Beverly Hills today
right LA I like dude I was about to have
a pain
it was crazy man that's pretty good I'm
thankful to be out here in the country
today max Knight yeah this is joked with
you ahead of time this is the North
Georgia of Lausanne that's it next time
you know where to hang out and stay
thank you so if people want to connect
with you
instagrams the best place for them to
find you yeah Instagram it's not you can
put it in the show notes eh ad w RI ght
2 7 8 is my Instagram panel and then
also if you're interested in more about
3 of 7 project that's just 3 of 7
project comm right and you can find that
on Apple podcasts and all that kinda
stuff so the the podcast portion is 3 of
7 podcast and yeah that's on Apple on
your blog and all that kind of you can
yeah you can find the podcast on the
website 3 of 7 project comm so yeah you
can find it if if you're meant to find
it you'll find it it's easy cool all
right man thank you brother thank you
god bless you
[Music]